estamos trabajando en el método de
corrientes de malla un método para
analizar circuitos en el vídeo pasado
teníamos este circuito pusimos estas
corrientes de malla en los lazos del
circuito y calculamos las corrientes de
malla fáciles de resolver que en este
circuito fue la corriente de malla y 3
porque aquí esta fuente de corriente
determina cuánto vale esta corriente de
malla así es que ya sabemos cuánto vale
la corriente de malla y 3 y después
utilizamos la ley de voltaje de kirch
para escribir estas dos ecuaciones
simultáneas que involucran a estas dos
variables independientes las corrientes
de malla que todavía no conocemos y
ahora en este vídeo vamos a resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones una cosa muy
importante que tenemos que recordar
cuando estemos poniendo las corrientes
de malla de nuestro circuito es que
estas corrientes de malla nos conviene
definirlas
en la misma dirección en este ejemplo
las definimos a favor de las manecillas
del reloj porque si las definimos así
con un patrón concreto vamos a obtener
este tipo de patrón y entonces va a
hacer que las cuentas sean más fáciles
de resolver porque tenemos aquí estos
patrones además de que nos ayuda a poner
estos signos bien ahora otra cosa muy
importante es definir estas corrientes
de malla justo en estas mallas y no en
cualquier otro lazo que se nos pueda
ocurrir ok no en un lazo que recorre a
todo el circuito los lazos que estamos
escogiendo para definir las corrientes
de malla son justo los lazos de malla
que recorren estas ventanas estos
espacios abiertos que tenemos aquí la
razón por la que utilizamos las mallas y
no cualquier otro lazo del circuito es
justo porque producen la cantidad
necesaria de ecuaciones simultáneas con
estas mallas ni nos faltan ecuaciones ni
tampoco nos sobran
así es que deja me muevo la pantalla y
vamos a empezar a trabajar con estas
ecuaciones y ahora empezamos con el paso
4 que es justo resolver estas ecuaciones
simultáneas paso 4 y lo primero que voy
a hacer es ordenar estas ecuaciones
vamos a poner todas las constantes de un
lado vamos a poner todos los términos
que tengan y 1 en un lugar y los
términos que tengan y 2 en otro lugar si
es que vemos con la primera ecuación nos
fijamos en la variable y uno está aquí
en dos lugares en esta ecuación estos
dos términos los podemos escribir como -
y entre paréntesis r 1 y luego + r2
r2 porque por aquí está su signo menos y
todo esto multiplicando a a1 y ahora
vamos con la variable y 2 que en esta
ecuación aparece una sola vez y tiene
como coeficiente más r 2 que multiplica
a y 2 el único término que no hemos
puesto de esta ecuación es la constante
de que la vamos a pasar del otro lado
del igual y nos queda menos b
así es que esta es la primera ecuación
ahora vamos a ordenar la segunda
ecuación podemos empezar por buscar los
términos que tengan y 1 este es el único
término que tiene y 1 escribimos por
aquí más r 2
1 luego buscamos los términos con y 2
por aquí tenemos menos r 2 y 2 - r 3 y 2
y menos r 4 y 2 así es que lo vamos a
escribir de esta forma como - y entre
paréntesis r 2 r2 más
r3 r3 y r4
4 x
2 y luego el último término que nos
falta de esta ecuación es el de ib3 pero
nosotros ya sabemos cuánto es y 3 porque
lo tenemos por aquí fue la corriente
fácil de resolver entonces nosotros
sabemos que 3 es igual a menos y tenemos
demasiados signos menos por aquí y menos
por menos da más pero luego tenemos que
multiplicar por menos r 4 claro que si
luego lo pasamos del otro lado del igual
nos queda igual a más r 4 x y r4 x y a
ver vamos a checarlo nuevamente menos r4
por menos nos da r 4 x menos y nos da
menos y por ere 4 pero luego cuando lo
pasamos del otro lado del igual nos
queda positivo
as r4 por iu y listo estaba muy bien
entonces ahora así es como se ven
nuestras ecuaciones simultáneas más
ordenadas ahora por supuesto que podemos
seguir utilizando estos símbolos para
las resistencias pero para explicarlo de
una forma un poco más comprensible
podría ser útil poner algunos números
concretos en lugar de estas letras por
lo que voy a poner por aquí un circuito
ya con ciertas resistencias específicas
y fuentes de voltaje y de corriente lo
único que hice con el circuito con el
que estamos trabajando es poner algunos
valores en especifico 5volts en la
fuente de voltaje 2000 y amperes en la
fuente de corriente un kilo o en la
resistencia de r 12 kilos oms en la
resistencia de 23 kilos en la
resistencia de 3 y 3 kilos homs en la
resistencia r 4 y bueno nada más para no
equivocarme vamos a poner estos valores
bajo de cada ecuación ok r1 es un kilo
r2 son dos kilos oms
r2 son dos kilos oms y por acá r2 son
dos kilos oms dos kilos
homs tres kilos oms
3 kilos oms y para que también son tres
kilos oms y por cierto aquí son 5volts
5volts y la y son 2.000 jumper es 2000 y
amperes bueno y ahora sí vamos a volver
a escribir estas ecuaciones pero con los
valores reales pero para eso necesitamos
un poquito más despacio así es que vamos
a mover a este por acá yo sé que no se
nos deben de olvidar todos estos kilos
oms pero por el momento como todas las
resistencias tiene un kilo oms sólo por
el momento nos vamos a olvidar de ellas
y más adelante las vamos a reincorporar
ok pero por aquí lo que tenemos es menos
12 estrés kilo
homs
por la variable
uno que todavía no conocemos y que
queremos encontrar más
2 kilos oms por la variable y 22 por y 2
igual menos 5 volts esta es la primera
ecuación vamos con la segunda la segunda
son dos por la variable y uno menos dos
más tres más tres esos son ocho kilos
oms 8 kilos oms por la variable y 2
tiene que ser igual a 3 kilos oms por 2
milián pérez 3 por 26 kilo por mil y se
cancelan y nos quedan simplemente oms
por amperes pero oms por amperes son
volts entonces y una vez podemos
escribir por aquí volts ahora lo que
realmente nos importa es encontrar estas
corrientes de malla para eso estamos
haciendo estas ecuaciones entonces lo
que vamos a hacer para resolverlas es
tomar toda esta primera ecuación
y multiplicar por cuatro porque de esa
forma la variable y 2 se va a eliminar y
nos va a quedar simplemente la variable
1 entonces para hacer esto necesitamos
más espacio vamos a multiplicar esta
ecuación por 4 y sumarle esta otra
ecuación y nos queda 4 x menos 3 eso es
menos 12 más 2 o sea menos 10 menos 10
1 y luego 4 x 2
eso es 8 menos 8 nos queda 0 x y 2 así
es que la variable y 2 se elimina
entonces esto nos queda igual a 4 x
menos cinco goles +6 volts o sea menos
14 volts pero aquí teníamos tres kilos
oms y dos kilos oms entonces aquí nos
falta agregar un 10 kilos oms y para
encontrar uno
1 lo único que hacemos es dividir entre
menos 10 kilos oms o sea que nos queda
menos 14 volts 14 volts entre menos 10
kilos oms por lo tanto nos queda que y
uno es igual menos con menos se cancela
14 entre 10 es igual a 1.4 y volts entre
kilo oms son mili amperes y ahora si ya
encontramos la corriente de malla y 110
que recordemos cómo estaban las cosas
teníamos aquí nuestro circuito y
definimos a uno como la corriente de
malla que fluya en esta malla en esta
dirección
uno es igual a 1.4 mili amperes esa es
una de nuestras variables independientes
y ahora ya que sabemos cuánto vale y uno
podemos encontrar y dos sólo tenemos que
escoger alguna de las ecuaciones que
teníamos originalmente y en ella
sustituir el valor y uno entonces por
ejemplo si tomamos esta tenemos dos
kilos oms por y uno pero y uno ya
sabemos que son 1.4 mili amperes y luego
teníamos por acá menos 8 kilos
y dos por i
2 y sabemos que eso es igual a 6 volts 6
holtz podemos olvidarnos de estas
unidades y poner simplemente 2 por 1.4
porque aquí kilo y mili se van a
cancelar y nos van a quedar oms por
amper es que son volts y luego menos 8
por y 2 tiene que ser igual a 6 y ahora
si encontremos y 2 menos 8 por 2 es
igual a 6 menos 2 por 1.4
esos son 2.8 por lo que y 2 es igual 6
menos 2.8 es 3.2 entre menos ocho menos
ocho y entonces y 2
y 2 es igual a menos 0.4 ahora con
respecto a las unidades
aquí tenemos volts aquí también tenemos
volts entonces por acá tenemos 3.2 volts
entre menos ocho kilos oms por lo que
estamos dividiendo volts entre kilo oms
y estos son mili amperes y ya terminamos
con dos y le podemos poner una cajita
alrededor entonces aquí en el circuito
ya encontramos esta corriente de malla
ya encontramos y dos que es igual a
menos 0.4
amperes y eso de que tengamos una
corriente de malla con un signo menos lo
único que significa es que en realidad
la corriente no está fluyendo en esta
dirección sino en la contraria y por eso
tenemos el signo menos pero de todas
formas podemos definir a la corriente
fluyendo en este sentido con una
corriente menos 0.4 mili amperes y bueno
desde el vídeo pasado ya sabemos que
esta otra corriente de malla y 3 es de
menos 2 mili amperes y ahora ya para
terminar de resolver este circuito vamos
a hacer una última cosa encontremos la
corriente del evento que fluye a través
de éste resistor y bueno también la
corriente que fluye a través de este
otro resistor queremos encontrar esta
corriente que es la corriente
r2 y también esta otra corriente que es
y r4 ahora y r2 es igual a esta
corriente menos esta corriente como
vimos en algún momento en el vídeo
pasado porque hay entonces y r2 es igual
a y 1 - y 2 y por lo tanto es igual a
1.4 milián pérez como tenemos aquí
escrito menos 2 que es menos 0.4 milián
pérez así es que esta corriente y r2 es
igual a 1.8
amperes vamos a resolver el último vamos
a resolver
r 4 la corriente que fluye a través del
resistor r 4 por cierto este es el
resistor r 2 y este es el resistor r 4 y
queremos encontrar esta corriente que
fluye a través del resistor r 4 ahora
como hemos visto ya esta corriente es
igual a esta corriente que fluye en la
misma dirección que en este caso es la
corriente y 2 más esta otra corriente
pero esta corriente está fluyendo en
dirección contraria por lo que le
tenemos que poner un menos y 3 y
entonces nos queda igual y 2 es menos
0.4 menos 0.4 menos y 30 y 3 es igual a
menos 2 miriam pérez entonces aquí
tenemos que poner menos 2 miriam pérez y
eso nos queda igual menos con menos nos
da más
- 0.4 es 1.6 mili amperes eso es la
corriente de elemento y r4 la corriente
que fluye a través del resistor r4 y
ahora si ahora si ya terminamos
utilizamos el método de corrientes de
malla para resolver este circuito